so this is summers in Kentucky on a new
album all real little wheeler buy on up
iTunes and or Amazon to my website
because we're having trouble like those
charts and not to kiss my own ass but I
will those charts are it means something
to me because it's not a level playing
field it's my fault but you know all the
other guys are selling out at fucking
Starbucks Walmart Bentley and this giant
racks of fucking you know Chris
Stapleton who I love Stapleton but you
know he's got giant racks of his shit at
Walmart that people throw in their cart
yes done fifty thousand a week it's just
Walmart damn and I fucked him if I
fucked it up I'm singing this garbage
this summer's are Kentucky
[Music]
sneaking out of my house I was just
sixteen matching in the dark down by the
creek mess around till we got cold
please drummers in Turkey they were hard
to beat
25 years later our life has changed
meeting girls on the road who are half
my age
some time to think about the creek when
I'm long studies
summers a Kentucky man I miss that clerk
used to press Christie up against my
mouth now you've had a couple kids and
it's all stretch down starting the thing
when we could figure it out so next if
you want to buy ignite
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you ever feel like ditching your
Miami red kids hit the road with the
Contra fight
this room for all young son of my lion
did you start our labs all over again
perchik a few got saggy tits but not
because of age lack shit why thank you
me the perfect fit
somebody took man I sure I give up on a
pussy any young shame up for your flabby
ass black now would be a new you an
apple looking pretty rough and I miss
[Laughter]